[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to behind the screens I'm
ash and I'm back from comic-con it was
so much fun and a little exhausting I
was in Hall H for every panel possible
so today I'm going to highlight the
biggest movie news from Marvel DC Comics
and [ __ ] all in one video so about a day
before Comic Con I noticed the Fox panel
changed its name to the Kingsmen panel
and yes this was true there was
absolutely no x-men universe news
whatsoever we watched the first ten
minutes of Kingsman the Golden Circle
which was great but here's the thing I
was already sold on Kingsman I love the
first one so to most people I wanted
some Dark Phoenix news anyway moving on
to Warner Brothers the trailer for ready
player one dropped which is now
receiving a contagious amount of
backlash i muted the words ready player
one on twitter already because i'm tired
of seeing the tweets but Warner Brothers
days of course the maker of the DC
Comics movies and they teased a massive
slate buckle up
it includes Shazam Aquaman Suicide Squad
to Justice League dark Batgirl Green
Lantern Corps flashpoint hands Wonder
Woman
so know Gotham City sirens no Nightwing
but still a lot of new information
however the rest of the panel's focus
was on Aquaman and Justice League the
unreleased Aquaman footage looked great
it was bright and colorful like Wonder
Woman it was a scene of two fishermen
getting pulled by something and then it
pans out to reveal these massive
underwater ships they're shaped like
rays and sharks
turns out it's Ocean masters army aka
the villain aka Aquaman's brother
injustice league knew Ben Affleck
immediately address rumors that he is
leaving his Batman role and does not get
along with director Matt Reeves I'm so
thrilled to do this video because you
asked about these amazing
[Applause]
two films have the security video and
you know Kevin tsujihara
two chromosome Geragos that's me going
to be our Batman you know I believe that
reads doing this is like I would be so
I'm really blown away excited and it's a
great time in the universe you get some
stuff from Chesapeake and we're really
really proud I wouldn't be surprised if
they still kill them all but then they
drop a new trailer for Justice League I
still don't have the vaguest idea what's
happening in this movie but I do know
this Ezra Miller's Barry Allen flash the
flash seems hilarious in it my biggest
takeaway from the Warner Brothers panel
was more Barry Allen please you really
do oh wow they just they really just
vanish oh let's rude
[Music]
so moving on to Marvel Studios who
headlines comic-con on Saturday night
and where I felt like a stenographer
trying to job Thomas flood of foods that
they laid on us right from the beginning
an intro video revealed that Michelle
Pfeiffer former champ woman is our Janet
Van Dyne in ant-man and the wasp she is
Hank Pimm's wife and former partners who
was lost in the Swanson realm in a
flashback shown in the first ant-man
then a smell of casting was revealed
including Hannah John came in as a
character called ghost Walton Goggins as
sunny birch Randall Park as agent Jimmy
woo and Laurence Fishburne as a doctor
bill foster then Kevin Feige announced
Captain Marvel will take place in his
1990 that's before the events of Iron
Man 1 and she'll be fighting a scroll
for these reptilian like shape-shifting
creatures who can take on appearances of
other beings which is really bad in Thor
Ragnarok news we got an extended first
look and a brand new trailer which
assembles the team of four Loki Valkyrie
and the Hulk to fight Helen to goddess
of death for Black Panther Weaver showed
an unreleased clip that was an epic
showdown inside a casino
Danai gurira is likely more badass than
shakaal himself plus a Michael B Jordan
plays a villain Erik kill monger who
fights black panther in a version of the
suit if we did our job correctly the bad
guy that people can really empathize
with kind of serious point of view you
know I feel like if you understand him
and understand and method to mathematics
a little bit I think if those who make
make for the most interesting villains
to actually watch and I think we I think
I think we might have pulled that off
and they close the panel with that same
Avengers infinity war footage from d23
that they have yet to release to the
public I don't know what they're waiting
for it's driving everybody mad but
anyway what would your favorite news out
of comic-con you can leave it in the
comments like subscribe and tweet me
I'll see you guys next week